came under Fire online after bragging
that she refused to switch seats so that
a mom could sit with their kids the mom
was in a middle seat and the other woman
I think was on the aisle and she refused
yeah I've been in a situation where
someone's asking me to switch a seat
before and sometimes usually I'd do it
if I can do it and it's easy I do get
annoyed if I get on the plane and
someone's already in my seat and they go
can we switch get in your seat when I
come you ask me then if someone was like
hey would you move and I see this every
once in a while would you take would you
leave first class and go sit and Coach
so I can sit next to my whatever get the
[__] out of here you should be kicked
off the plane while it's in the air if
you ask someone that I don't care what
the deal is that's not cool
uh and if someone asks you to move from
like a window or an aisle into a middle
not cool if you can go middle to Middle
hey let's switch it up so I'm okay with
telling someone no
even if it's a mom with their kids it
kind of sucks if it would work out great
but I'm not going to have a shitty
flight because of you